hi there steve coffin here today today
i'm going to talk about speaking
how do we learn to speak better everyone
wants to speak better we learn a
language in order to speak usually
um and i'm going to do that because
there were a few questions here on the
forum a few comments
one person asked how do we start
speaking
and there's a lengthier comment that i'm
going to get to about this issue of
whether we speak from the beginning or
not
there was also a request for a tutorial
about how to you know get more out of
link
we do run these um
webinars uh which are available and i
will put a link to where you can find
them
in the description box uh
but the one consideration right now is
that we are making a few changes to link
to bring the the web version more in
line with the uh
the uh
ios uh you know mobile and android
mobile app so i'm gonna wait until we
have those in place then we might do
some videos on how to get more out of
link now
to speak better
i say to speak better
listen more
okay eventually to speak better you have
to speak a lot however if you don't have
a good grounding in the language if you
don't have familiarity if you can't
understand what is said
then you are not going to speak well
so uh
let and
just by the way i think i might after
this video do a video in japanese
because someone asked me to talk about
english language instruction in japan
i'm not really qualified to talk about
that because i've been away from japan
for so long
i don't necessarily know how they teach
in the classroom
however i know that there is a
tremendous obsession with toeic
if you go into a bookstore in japan if
you go to the language learning section
it will be overwhelmingly devoted to
english and 50 of the books
there will be books on how to ace toeic
vocabulary for toeic and then the
japanese study these lists of vocabulary
however
if you look at the results
of test takers in different countries
around the world japan is right near the
bottom along with
generally other asian countries
the average score is like
500 or something or less 400 something
which is a very low level in my opinion
and when you are at that level you
aren't going to be able to speak well
period
and
um
toeic results basically reflect your
vocabulary in my opinion your vocabulary
and your ability to read and your
ability to understand when you're
listening
so
if those japanese learners want to speak
better they first of all have to upgrade
their listening and reading capabilities
a little further on this subject
uh you know before we had writing
which is long before we had mb mp3
players of course you could only learn
the language by speaking with someone
and while speaking to someone you would
listen to them and you would slowly
learn the language then writing was
invented and writing is a way of
recording the language
so that without being face to face with
a native speaker you can now interact
with the language and you can acquire
words and phrases and become familiar
with the language
now with the advent of
you know audio recorders and now very
convenient you know mp3 technology
you can read something and then listen
to it and listening to it
is very powerful and it's interesting in
analyzing these toeic results
that when they said okay what correlates
to success on toeic
the correlation to vocabulary level
uh on the reading part of toeic toeic is
by the way test of english
i don't know something it's a very
common test for those of you not
familiar with toeic it's a very common
and i think quite a good test less
expensive than toefl which establishes
your level in the language it's used by
employers it's used by
other people to determine roughly where
you are in the language
it's a big industry millions of people
worldwide take toeic they found that
your vocabulary correlates very closely
to the results on the written like the
reading portion of toeic
however correlates correlates less well
with the listening portion of toeic this
is not surprising
most people spend more time reading and
not enough time listening
in my own language learning i listen
three times as much as i read
and
both the reading and the listening when
combined start to make you familiar with
the language the language starts to
become your own the brain gets used to
it so that at some point you initiate
speaking and the better you are the
better you understand the greater the
vocabulary the better you're going to do
however
to answer one question when you start
speaking whenever that is you are going
to have difficulty you are going to have
difficulty however if you have a large
vocabulary and you understand well you
can engage in more meaningful
conversations on more meaningful
subjects and so you will progress more
quickly
but you still have to continue with
listening listening and reading and i
can consider them almost the same in a
way because when you are reading very
often when we're reading in a foreign
language we are vocalizing the foreign
language but when we're reading we see
the word so it's easier when we listen
without seeing the words it's more
difficult so you have to put a lot of
effort into listening okay now
the other reason i wanted to
talk about the subject
is no before i leave japan and i'll get
on to japan like in japan
when you google for or look up words
that people search for related to
english learning ego kaiwa english
conversation is a big one somehow people
think that if they have lots of english
conversation they're going to improve
their speaking
i don't believe that
unless you are immersed with native
speakers
but very often the ego kaiwa is five or
six or ten japanese people sitting
around with maybe one native speaker
most of what they're listening to is
other japanese people that's not very
helpful i remember my first month in
japan
i went to a language school it was under
tokyo tower
run by a gentleman i think his name was
mr nito guri he toguri sensei
and his big slogan was koko roto kokoro
heart to heart and we would all sit
around and try and stumble out you know
mumble say you know something in
japanese
i was committed for a month i stayed for
a month and i got out of there because i
would far rather listen to
japanese spoken by a native speaker
i didn't want to hear americans or
frenchmen
you know butchering the japanese
language i wanted to hear the language i
wanted to listen to the language read
the language build up my capability in
the language and then i can interact
with japanese people and improve quickly
so now there was a comment here from
someone whose name was
i can't remember
matt
sharon i don't know
so he says
you know there's a lot to unpack here
and then he
you know tells us what his uh you know
degrees are relating to linguistics and
english teaching credentials okay i'm
not necessarily impressed because and
he's arguing that that you have to start
speaking from the beginning for reasons
that i'll explain here but there are
lots of people who have similar
credentials who don't agree with that
such as steven crash and so the
credentials is kind of irrelevant to me
uh he just also teach music and you
can't learn
to play music or drums if you don't
actually drum okay
you can't learn to play music if you've
never heard music okay so i'm not sure
the music applies to language in any
case but certainly if you have never
heard a song it's more difficult to
learn to play it so i think the
listening analogy does apply but then he
goes on to say meaningful input is
important blah blah blah but you have to
speak to notice your own abilities and
shortcomings it gives you a better
opportunity to improve by targeting
problem areas all of this is true but it
doesn't matter when you do it okay you
can build up quite a lot of potential in
the language
and then start speaking so when you
start to speak it should be
entirely up to you
if you are in a situation where looking
at your classmate unsure of what to say
or what you should be doing then either
you didn't understand the exercise or
the teacher isn't going about the lesson
properly how about we're not in a
classroom how about i'm not dealing with
my classmates i'm just learning on my
own which i think is more intensive
interaction with the language
and then he finally he ends up by saying
that you know i gave i can't remember he
refers to it steve's greek restaurant
story
being pushed to produce he was forced to
use the higher level processing
necessary blah blah blah yeah i think i
went to a restaurant here in vancouver
tried to say something in greek found i
wasn't able to say anything quickly
retreated and didn't attempt to speak
the language again
for at least several months and then
before going to greece i did talk to
people on italki quite a bit and i did
progress quite a bit when i was ready
for it when i felt like doing it
so he then says
that uh yeah at any rate he's saying you
should speak from the beginning because
it identifies your gaps and so forth and
so on of course speaking identifies your
gaps but you don't have to do it from
the beginning what you really have to do
in my opinion is focus on reading and
listening get it in you
and if at an early stage you engage in
conversation especially with other
non-native speakers such as in a
classroom you're wasting your time
and because you're going to pick up the
pronunciation and the errors that the
your fellow classmates have which you
don't want you want to get like when i
listen now to my arabic it's becoming
more and more familiar more and more
comfortable more and more a part of me
and even with regard to pronunciation he
says at the very beginning you should
attempt to pronounce et cetera et cetera
i find that at the very beginning before
i have listened to a lot of the language
i cannot hear
the
vowel sounds clearly the different
aspects of the pronunciation you know i
mentioned that i once got on a forum
when i was starting to learn russian and
i thought i was really quite cool that i
could say some things in russian and i
put up a recording of my spell myself
speaking russian i got roundly
criticized i couldn't really hear it
properly
six months later when i attempt to speak
i've got a better sense of the
intonation better sense of the
pronunciation so
once again if you want to speak better
if you want to speak better make sure
you
listen more like those
those toeic
people in their test
the typically their vocabulary level
corresponds to a corresponds very
closely to the results on the written
test but on the uh
listening test the correlation is less
strong because most people don't listen
enough so listen a lot listen more than
you read focus on input don't worry too
much about when you start speaking
recognize that whenever you start
speaking
you're going to struggle and that
ultimately to speak really well you're
going to have to speak a lot but even as
you up your you know the increased
amount of speaking you're doing continue
with your input
reading and listening activities all
right there you have it and i will if i
can remember what i said i think i'll
say the same in japanese bye for now
[Music]
you